A Song of Ice and Fire is a huge, complicated
story, with literally thousands of characters
– twenty-two of whom are named Jon – so
it’s fair enough that the show, Game of
Thrones, had to simplify things a bit by cutting
and combining many characters.
It’s a shame though, because many of even
the minor characters have heaps of really
cool backstories, and connections, and layers
to them, that add a lot to the series.
A good example is Thoros of Myr.
We know him in the show as a member of the
“brotherhood without banners”, the outlaw
group who capture Arya, Gendry and Hot Pie
in Season 3.
The leader of the brotherhood, Beric Dondarrion,
is killed by the Hound, but then Thoros resurrects
Beric using the power of the Red God, R’hllor
– which may forshadow a certain other red
priest resurrecting a certain Jon Snow, not
to name any names, but anyway, that’s basically
Thoros’ role in the show so far.
But in the books, there’s more to his story.
Thoros was born in the city of Myr.
He was the youngest of eight children, so
his father gave him to a temple of R’hllor,
where Thoros was trained to be a red priest.
He “prayed the prayers and … spoke the
spells”, and did sometimes see visions in
flames, but he wasn’t much of a believer,
being more interested in food and women.
Eventually he was sent to Westeros to convert
King Aerys Targaryen to the faith of the Red
God.
The temple figured that since Mad Aerys infamously
“loved fire”, he might like the Lord of
Light, but Thoros failed to convert Aerys.
When Aerys was overthrown, Thoros became bros
with the new king, Robert Baratheon.
“They were pease in a pod … both gluttons
and sots” – who loved eating and drinking
and whoring and fighting . Thoros would fight
in tourneys with his sword alight with wildfire
. And he fought in the Greyjoy Rebellion,
“setting ironmen afire with every slash”
of his “flaming sword” . So he sounds
like quite the warrior, but in the same way
that Bobby B is a pretty shitty king, Thoros
is a pretty shitty priest . Tywin calls him
a “fat jape” , and Gendry’s master Tobho
– who sells Thoros the swords he sets afire
– calls him “a fraud”, and “as bad
a priest as there ever was” . Thoros apparently
gives up trying to convert anyone, and doesn’t
seem to even believe in R’hllor anymore.
But all that changes in the War of the Five
Kings.
In Book 1, the Mountain, Gregor Clegane, starts
brutally raiding in the riverlands . So Ned
Stark, acting on the behalf of King Robert,
orders a group of men to go stop him.
The group is led by Lord Beric Dondarrion,
and includes about a hundred men, including
Thoros.
So the men go after the Mountain, but at the
Mummer’s Ford, they’re ambushed – the
whole thing was a trap designed by Tywin Lannister
to get Ned – the only reason it didn’t
work was ‘cause Ned couldn’t come because
Jaime injured his leg . So anyway, the group
is smashed by the Mountain’s men.
Some of them manage to escape, and regroup,
but Beric is mortally wounded, with a lance
run through his chest.
Thoros, distraught over his dying friend,
performs a “death rite” of the red priests,
called the “last kiss”, breathing fire
into Beric’s body.
To Thoros’ shock, the dead man shudders,
his eyes come open, and Beric is brought back
to life .
This causes a religious reawakening for Thoros,
he says “The Lord of Light has woken in
[his] heart” .
As the remnants of Beric’s men regroup,
Thoros converts them to his rediscovered faith
, binding them together as a holy brotherhood,
sworn to serve their realm, their god, and
each other . Even after King Robert dies,
the brotherhood fights on in his name, protecting
the common people from the ravages of raiders
like Gregor . They fight a guerrilla war against
the Lannisters in the riverlands, striking
suddenly , then “vanishing back into the
woods” . Thoros fights in these battles
with his flaming sword, he sees visions in
his flames of the future, present and past
, and he resurrects Beric five more times
as he keeps dying in his fights.
Thoros is convinced that he’s an “instrument”
of “God” , he’s finally doing something
with his life that he believes in.
And it changes him.
When Arya first sees Thoros with the brotherhood,
she hardly believes it’s him.
She “remember[s] the red priest as fat,
with a smooth face and a shiny bald head”.
But now Thoros “ha[s] a droopy face and
a full head of shaggy grey hair”.
Thoros says that a year in the wild has melted
the flesh off him, that “[he is] less than
[he] was, but more” . This change in appearance
mirrors the change in his character from a
“glutton” and a “sot”, a fat joke
of a priest, to a man filled with righteous
purpose and faith.
But his story doesn’t end there.
] In the last Brienne chapter of Feast, we
hear that Beric Dondarrion has died a final
time, giving his “flame of life” to the
dead Catelyn Stark, who rises as Lady Stoneheart
. Stoneheart is totally different to what
Catelyn was like alive, she’s vengeful,
hateful , completely without mercy , and as
the new leader of the “brotherhood”, she
begins a brutal campaign killing everyone
who’s in any way connected to the Red Wedding,
even people who really weren’t responsible,
like Petyr and Merrett Frey , she evens hangs
Podrick – though Pod is apparently still
alive , so don’t worry – but the point
is that under Stoneheart, the brotherhood
does some fucked up stuff . Under Beric, they
would always give their captives a trial,
they “won’t kill a man unless something’s
proved against him” , but Stoneheart will
hang anyone who she deems guilty . Thoros
loses his belief that what they’re doing
is just , he loses his belief in himself,
calling himself a “pink pretender”, “a
bad priest and a worse wizard” . He sees
the brotherhood, his brotherhood, deteriorate
from something noble and righteous and holy
to something crueller and darker . He says
that “War makes monsters of us all”.
So… where can Thoros go from here?
Maybe Thoros could just leave, kinda like
the Hound did – the popular Gravedigger
theory suggests that Sandor Clegane is not
dead, but living a life of peace and atonement
as a monk on the Quiet Isle.
Maybe Thoros could do something similar, go
back to a red temple in Essos and meditate
on his God and his place in the world.
Alternatively, he could try to finish what
he started, maybe try to put the brotherhood
back on a righteous path by killing Lady Stoneheart.
Thoros after all is a fire priest with a flaming
sword, and the undead in this story generally
are vulnerable to fire.
Trying to kill Stoneheart could risk Thoros’
life, but he might think it’s worth the
sacrifice – Thoros tells Brienne that “it
does not matter how a man begins, but only
how he ends”.
Sacrificing himself to kill Stoneheart could
make a great ending for Thoros, a dramatic
act of selflessness by a formerly selfish
man.
So it could go a bunch of ways, but the point
is that Thoros is a really fascinating character,
someone who transforms from a drunken warrior,
to a righteous priest, to a man again filled
with doubts about what he’s become.
It’ll be great to see how his story ends
in the books – he might even turn up again
in the show, we’ll have to wait and see,
it’s not clear if the show will include
the whole Stoneheart thing.
By the way, this artwork of Stoneheart was
created by Ertaç Altınöz, you might like
to check out his DeviantArt for more.
Anyway, hope you enjoyed this video.
Many thanks to all supporters on Patreon,
including Reverend Xandria, @MrFifaSA, Cameron
Weiss, @Vineyarddawg, Michael Appell, Jason
Rattray, Eric Pakurar, Sheila M. Tierney,
Akash Parthasarathy, Fancy Ams, Karin Granström,
Ben Greenhagen, Marc Raimondi, MsLouisez,
Guillaume Lejeune, Ruud Lipper, xxxnatxcutexxx,
Magyar Nikolett Tímea, Freyja Donkersloot,
Podrick Targaryen, Lorenzo89er, Angelica Saunderson,
Brad Smoley, dali, Jamal, Greg and Bob.
Thank you again, and see you next time.